welcome back to las vegas now this new
suv on the market had me ready
to turn my crossover in let's head to
findlay acura
[Music]
we're here in the valley auto mall here
in henderson and our goal really is to
create a customer for life we really try
and take care of everyone make sure
everyone has a great experience here at
finley acura
so acura just launched the new 2022 mdx
we're very excited about it they've
really led the segment in the luxury
third row suv segment with the mdx
since its original launch with the
redesign we've had a huge
amount of excitement about it we have a
lot of pre-orders coming in
they've really listened to everyone's
feedback over the years
from the previous generation and
incorporated all of those
aspects while still keeping their
reliability
you know the performance aspect and
really
upping the styling and uh the utility
it's really for anybody it is the third
row suv so you can fit the whole family
in there
but most of our a lot of our clients are
throwing that third row down too
just you know just having a little more
room than a
typical sedan so you mentioned space
absolutely this vehicle has a ton of
space so i want to test it out
so not only did they increase the uh
storage space and the cubic feet on
the interior the trunk space they also
really made this second row versatile
you can have the full bench here
or you can fold that down to have a
center console you can also completely
remove it and make these in the
captain's chairs wow look at that
and then the trunk i heard is pretty
cool too with the trunk they did
increase that
storage space they also have the
hidden storage compartment underneath
the cover for that can be flipped over
it's reversible
all weather on one side carpeted on the
other and it also drops down to put that
all-weather flooring on the lower end
so plenty of space to kick back and
chill and relax
with a view let's talk about the
panoramic sunroom
absolutely the panoramic sunroof is
available entry-level with the mdx
mdx can also this isn't even an extra
feature this is
just standard wow what a luxury and
let's talk about the design now because
i
can't take my eyes off of this interior
yes they
redid all of the styling here with a
12.3 inch
display for all of your apple carplay
android auto that's all wireless here
you also have a 12.3 inch digital um
cluster display here in the front as
well keep the driver fully um
connected and entertained and
entertained
can i just take this one with me or
this one is actually sold really this
one is whoever
whoever got this is very lucky so
whether you're going out to
lake mead or you're heading up to mount
charleston cruising the strip
the mdx has everything you could ask for
look i am sold okay check out findlay
acura
on auto mall drive in henderson you can
call 702-982-4100 or just visit
findlayacura.com lindsey